so let's think about what other repeated
code can be factored out here even
though it's a tiny piece of logic the
code that adds a dot local property to a
new car object is being written twice
here how do you think we could go about
factoring that out well we can use the
same technique we did of writing a
function that does work for us over and
over again and I'm gonna give this
function the name car-like since its job
is to augment an object with the
properties needed to be considered a car
now it's true that in this
oversimplified example the function
we're gonna be writing will do almost
nothing since cars seem to be pretty
simple they really only have a dot local
property on them but in a real program
objects have a lot more properties so
this car like function should be made to
take some car object as an input then do
some work on it and then return it and
when we call it on our car objects we
expect it to add this dot local property
for us as such we'll need to pass the
location value into car like so that it
knows what to set the cars location to
when a function like this one takes in
an object as its input and then augments
that object with some properties or
functionality the car like function here
would qualify as a decorator it's common
to use adjectives as the names for your
decorator functions hence the name car
like